i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family to really just support each other
no matter what we're going through the
kardashians support each other through
it
all and on tuesday the famous fam sent
all their love to kim kardashian's
estranged husband kanye west on his 44th
birthday
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
kris jenner posted this snap with kanye
to her insta story wishing the rapper a
happy birthday
while chloe shared this pic with kanye
her sister kim
and her boyfriend tristan thompson
alongside the caption quote
happy birthday to my brother for life
have the best birthday yay
sending you love and endless blessings
and kim
she slid into the comments of her
sister's post with a single red balloon
emoji
at the end of the day life is about
being happy being
who you are of course this all comes
after the kkw
beauty founder filed for divorce from
kanye after six years of marriage in
february
a source previously told et that kim
wouldn't shy away from addressing her
highly publicized marital issues on the
20th and final season of keeping up with
the kardashians
i think he deserves someone that can go
support his every move
and go follow him all over the place and
move to wyoming i can't do that
he should have a wife that supports his
every move and travels with him and does
everything and
and i can't i feel like a failure that
it's like a third
marriage yeah i feel like a loser
but i can't even think about that like i
want to be happy and
during part one of the series finale
that's just what happened
in a sneak peek at part two kim sits
down with her mom
and opens up about the end of her
marriage i didn't come this far just to
come this far
and not be happy last month a source
told et
that kim is quote in a great headspace
and moving on in the months since filing
for divorce
adding that kim is really focused on her
family and has been spending the
majority of her time with the kids
in life what i've learned is you just
kind of have to go with it
kim is continuing to be a great mom and
focusing on work
her life is definitely on the upswing